Wir wollen blicken auf den internationalen Fußball der Männer. Heute mit dabei, zumindest in der ersten Aufnahme, Spanien und Italien, was alles noch kommt. Ich weiß es selbst, zu diesem Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme noch nicht. Guckt in die Show Notes, wenn ihr es nicht wissen wollt oder hört doch einfach die ganze Folge. Jetzt geht's los.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hallo und herzlich Willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer und Hallo und herzlich Willkommen Fabian Pakulat. Servus Fabian, schön, dass du da bist. Guten Morgen. Schön, dass du es geschafft hast und schön, dass Christian Bernhard neben mir sitzt.
Stark. Ich habe kurz versucht, das in Bezug zu setzen zur Bundesliga. Auch 15 Millionen Euro Personaletat hatte damals im Zweitliga-Jahr der VfL Bochum. Jetzt sind sie auf 19. Dann denkt man sich so, naja, dann ist es ja gar nicht so beeindruckend. Aber jetzt lese ich euch mal ein paar andere vor. HSV, 40 Millionen Personaletat, Fortuna Düsseldorf, 24 Millionen Personaletat. Also jetzt alles lauten offizielle DFL-Zahlen und so weiter.
Also ich finde, 15 ist schon echt. Ich meine, das sind ja immer Schätzungen, ist ja klar. Aber wenn es auch nur annähernd stimmt, dann ist das wirklich... Die haben letztes Jahr nicht nur Jülmann verloren, im Sommer auch Umtiti, der damals, der vom Barca dahin kam, eine herausragende Saison gespielt hat. Und haben einfach clever eingekauft, weil Corvino Nässen davon hat. Und während hier Verona, Cali, Reudinese, Fosinone, Empoli, Sassuolo alle noch zittern, wird in Lettscher schon seit dem vergangenen Sonntag gefeiert.
Sehr schön. Ich habe den perfekten Bundesligavergleich mal wiedergefunden, weil nur darum geht es in der Liga.
Absolut.
Heidenheim. Etat 15 Millionen. Und wer hat es in der Bundesliga geschafft, dass er nicht mehr zittern muss und andere noch zittern? Also quasi das italienische Heidenheim. Kannst du das bitte etablieren, dass auch in der EAA so drüber berichtet wird?
Ja, ich habe mir einen ausgepickt, mit dem keiner viel gesetzt hat, nämlich den aktuellen Trainer von Celta de Vigo, Claudio Chiraldes. Der ist erst 36 Jahre alt, kam von der zweiten Mannschaft von Celta de Vigo und hat den Trainerstuhl übernommen vor ein paar Wochen von Rafa Benitez, der eigentlich zu Celta de Vigo jetzt in der Jubiläumssaison, ich weiß nicht, ob es das 100-jährige Jubiläum oder das 120-jährige, irgendein tolles Jubiläum haben sie dieses Jahr. Sorry, dass ich nicht genau weiß, wie viele Jahre das ist. Aber er sollte eigentlich Celta de Vigo wieder zu neuen Ruhm verhelfen. Und es sah ganz lange und böse nach Abstieg aus. Dann wurde Benitez vor die Tür gesetzt und man hat sich für eine interne Lösung entschieden, eben für diesen Claudio Chiraldes, 36 Jahre, war vorher Trainer der zweiten Mannschaft, ist Galizia, ist sogar jünger als einer seiner besten Spieler, nämlich Yago Aspas. Und hat es aber geschafft. Es ist noch nicht mathematisch soweit, aber er hat tatsächlich wichtige Punkte eingefahren im Abstiegskampf. Sie sind jetzt fünf Punkte drüber bei zwei ausstehenden Spielen. Es sieht sehr gut aus, vor allen Dingen nach dem gestrigen Sieg gegen Athletic Bilbao. Da waren sie schon 0-1 hinten und haben noch das Spiel gedreht, mit 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Unwahrscheinlich wichtig, sonst wären sie jetzt mit Cadiz tatsächlich in einem herben Zweikampf gesteckt, was den letzten Abstiegsplatz anbelangt. Dementsprechend muss ich sagen, Hut ab vor dem Mann, der seine erste Profi-Laufstation hat, mit nur 36 Jahren, in einer extrem schwierigen Situation. Der macht das sehr ordentlich. Dementsprechend könnte auch gut sein, dass wir in den nächsten Jahren noch ein bisschen was von dem jungen Mann hören.
Ich liebe die Anzang Hero-Kategorie. Da kommt wirklich die interessante Geschichte. Lass mal was von Sportdirektor von Lecce über den neuen Interimstrainer von Celta Vigo. Mega gut, hätte ich schon viel früher einführen müssen hier in der Liga Tour. So, den Moment des Spieltags haben wir noch.
Ja, da haben wir ja ein bisschen Input bekommen von unseren italienischen Zuschauern, Zuhörern. Alessandro, Spitzname Billy, Costa Curta, sagt vielleicht einigen noch was, AC Milan, Verteidigerlagende in den Jahren mit Parese, mit Maldinia, eine der beeindruckendsten defensiven Europas gebildet und der mittlerweile sein Geld auch als TV-Experte verdient und am vergangenen Wochenende war er da mit vollem Körpereinsatz dabei, nämlich es ging auch um das Milan-Spiel und da wollte er eine Szene nochmal vor dem großen Bildschirm im TV-Studio eindrucksvoll nachzeichnen und hat eine Rettungsschätzung, eine Defensiv- Rettungstat nachgespielt, nämlich so eine eingesprungene Grätsche und in dem Moment, wo er es macht, zack, greift er sich hinten an den Oberschenkel, ist es beim Herrn Costa-Curta reingefahren. Sie sind auch sofort in die Werbung gegangen, das ist auch witzig. Also es ist nichts Schlimmes passiert, aber er hat sich logisch eine Zerrung zugezogen und kleiner mit einem Lächeln zwinkern. Er passt sich da mit der Milan-Saison an, denn da waren ja auch mehr oder weniger alle Verteidiger, sowohl Ciao, als auch Tumori, als auch Quier wochenlang teilweise Kalulu, wochenlang monatelang verletzt, als auch Costa-Curta. Obwohl er nicht mehr das Milan-Trikot trägt, hat er sich irgendwie mit vollem Einsatz da auch in diese jetzt am Ende nochmal da gut in die Milan-Reihe eingereiht.
Sehr schön. Ja, vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank da auch an den Input, den wir da bekommen haben. Ich werde es nachreichen bzw. jetzt kann ich es noch schnell raussuchen. Ich finde es leider nicht mehr. Ich werde es verlinken in den Show Notes. Herzlichen Dank auf jeden Fall dafür, dass ihr euch da gemeldet habt und dann hat Fabian noch einen Moment des Spiels.
Ja, wie gesagt, in der Liga ist ja ein bisschen die Luft raus, deswegen kann ich jetzt gar nicht so mit einem richtig tollen emotionalen Moment dienen. Vielleicht zwei Anmerkungen zu den letzten zwei Spieltagen, weil wir haben ja gerade unter der Woche gerade einen Spieltag laufen. Real Madrid marschiert gerade mit einem 4-0- und einem 5-0-Sieg nochmal so durch die letzten Ligaspiele. Also, die schonen sich, die lassen ihre zweite Gilde spielen und die knipsen natürlich auch schön. Da möchte sich jeder noch fürs Champions League-Finale empfehlen. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine krasse Momentaufnahme. Und was ich ganz witzig fand, war nach dem Spiel von Mallorca, die ja noch im Abstiegskampf stecken, ich glaube mit 36 Punkte, 4 Punkte nur vor Cadiz, da wurde nach der Pressekonferenz der Trainer gefragt, ob er sich denn dann das Spiel von Cadiz auch anschauen würde. Javier Aguirre, der Mexikaner, der sehr amüsante Pressekonferenzen gibt und immer sehr witzige Kommentare und sehr ehrliche Kommentare abgibt. Und der meinte, er glaubt nicht, weil es hängt alles von seiner Frau ab, von Sylvia, weil er muss wahrscheinlich ins Kino oder er muss wieder Wasser oder Milch für sie kaufen oder sonst irgendwas, also er wird es wahrscheinlich nicht anschauen können. Ja, ist ja auch egal, er muss sich ja dann auf sein Team konzentrieren und so weiter, hat dann wieder den Bogen so ein bisschen gespannt. Aber es hängt im Hause Aguirre natürlich alles von der Ehefrau ab.
Oh, ein bisschen antiquiertes Rollenbild, das dann auch so zu thematisieren. Aber gut, wir nehmen es hin. The Butcher war derjenige, der den Hinweis hinterlassen hat. Nee, war es auch nicht. Warum gibt es denn hier so viele Ligatur-Threads? Ich weiß nicht, ich werde es mal rausgesucht haben. Ihr zwei, ich danke euch sehr, das hat wieder sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Ich habe wieder sehr viel gelernt. Das ist der Vorteil, wenn man nur zu dritt ist, dass wir richtig plaudern konnten, das war sehr nett. Herzlichen Dank an Fabian Pakulat, wie immer. Und vielen Dank, Christian Bernhard. Danke dir für deine Zeit.
Danke, Max, danke Fabian, großen Spaß gemacht.
Aber wirklich, und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich natürlich auch für eure Aufmerksamkeit und für euren Support. Ich moderiere hier jetzt einfach schon ab und ich werde auch das Outro spielen, denn stand jetzt, weiß ich immer noch nicht, wahrscheinlich wird es jetzt doch nicht geklappt haben, dass wir noch über die Premier League sprechen. Es tut mir sehr leid, es hängt mit der verfügbarkeit, terminlichen Verfügbarkeit der möglichen Experten hier zusammen und da könnt ihr ja auch nichts für. Deswegen moderiere ich jetzt hier ab, falls noch was danach kommt, dann werdet ihr es am Timecode gerade merken. Ich danke sehr, sehr herzlich allen Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützern des Rasenfunks. In diesem Fall möchte ich mich bedanken bei Kunibert, bei Stefan, bei Markus aus Heidenheim, bei Scotty Guinness, bei Benjamin und bei Guido. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubgegangen und haben uns unterstützt. Geht via Paypal, Kreditkarte, Direktüberweisung und so weiter. Einen Hinweis möchte ich aber noch machen, wenn euch EM-Coverage interessiert, von der ich selber noch nicht weiß, wie sie aussehen wird. Aber was ich weiß, ist, ihr müsst dafür den Rasenfunk Nationalteams Feed abonnieren. Alle EM-Sendungen zu den deutschen Spielen, Vorschau, Rückblick, alles wird dort erscheinen. Auch das werde ich verlinken. In diesem Sinne, bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Bleibt gesund. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.